in many ways black widow is marvel's
batman at least in the mcu she
ostensibly has no superpowers and yet
she's able to go toe-to-toe with far
more powerful characters gods and
monsters and robots she does this to a
combination of tenacity agility and
mobility which she uses to perform these
awesome takedown moves on her opponents
and the really interesting thing about
black widow is that there is some
in-universe explanation as to why she's
able to do these things her training by
the red room incorporated lots of ballet
training and as we're going to see
ballet actually has a lot of useful
secrets that many of us can benefit from
even if we have no interest in dance
so that's the point using black widow as
inspiration for a more mobile agile and
nimble form of training if all you've
ever focused on is strength and
explosiveness you may be surprised at
just how useful a little poise balance
and mobility can be
this type of training can take your
performance to the next level and it's
something few of us have explored
let's take a look at some concepts from
dance and see if they can help make our
movements that much more deadly just
like black widow so mobility is a big
issue for many of us more than we often
realize if you're interested in general
athletic performance and strength a
number of dance drills can be
transformative for example consider just
how many people struggle with tight
hamstrings often as a result of desk
jobs
tight hamstrings can cause pain in the
lower back as well as keeping a number
of calisthenics movements off limits
worse a lot of hamstring stretches fail
to solve this problem bend down to touch
your toes and you'll likely find that
your lower back rounds to compensate for
the lack of mobility
the result is that in trying to be a
good girl or boy and improve your
mobility you actually end up hurting
your back more but instead of a pike try
the leg lift straighten your supporting
leg and lift the other one directly
upwards with this movement you're
stretching the hamstrings while keeping
the back in a much flatter position
moreover you're actually employing
strength to train real mobility by
engaging the working muscles and
relaxing the antagonists
this is what mobility really boils down
to control over your nervous system and
awareness of the entire body and it's
not just a stretch then it's actually a
strength challenge and you might find
that your legs really burn much more
than you're expecting and noah is this
kind of training more effective than in
bar class
so bar class is training against a bar
for ballet focused controller mobility a
lot of this involves supporting your
weight ever so slightly on a bar hence
the name while performing a range of leg
extensions lateral and forwards lifts
with control
in many cases you'll then draw tiny
circles with the extended legs for 30
seconds reverse direction and place back
down one big focus in bar training and
that applies to a lot of movements
whether it's a leg lift or something
like a plie is pelvis control and this
is once again a really under utilized
aspect of strength and performance being
able to get your pelvis into the correct
position is crucial for so many
different exercises and it can lead to
injury if you don't know how to do this
but unfortunately that's exactly the
problem so many of us have no idea how
to control our pelvis because we're
sitting on our butts all day we end up
putting our spines into these unusual
positions that often result in an
anterior pelvic tilt and we've lost the
mind muscle connection to allow
ourselves to move our spines the way
that we really need to
in bar training you're encouraged to
tuck the pelvis underneath during
movements like the plie and the leg lift
and this helps to maintain a neutral
spine thereby creating poise and
alignment to make balance much easier
and to help you jump higher and of
course it looks nice as well now there
are some that say that focusing too much
on tucking the pelvis like this can
actually be a bad thing if you're
someone who does a lot of ballet but for
the majority of us it's hardly going to
be because most of us have anterior
pelvic tilt the exact opposite problem
so this is just a perfect example of how
ballet and dance in general can teach
you to be more aware of your body and to
reawaken that mind muscle connection to
improve the quality of your movement to
reduce injury and to perform better and
of course this type of training also
requires balance and stability on the
supporting leg especially if you also
practice it without the bar
this might feel like a flexibility
routine but you'll build real strength
and control here too
[Music]
and anyway everyone should aspire to
graceful precise movement
black widow movement
these extensions are performed from a
range of different positions in fact
this is true of most ballet moves there
are five basic ballet positions
literally named first second third
fourth and fifth each of which involve
turning the feet out to varying degrees
tight tips can be a huge issue for some
people and even make it impossible to
get into a deep squat without collapsing
the knees
these drills will prevent injury and
allow you to express power from a range
of different positions i recently
recommended performing the sumo squat
with leg lift to work both abductors and
adductors to build simultaneous strength
and mobility
but another similar movement from ballet
is the standard plie squat plie
literally means bending the knees and
this is a squatting movement with the
legs and feet turned out you can also
perform a plie squat which is
essentially the same movement adapted
into an exercise and in the plie squat
what you're going to be doing is placing
your feet just wider than shoulder width
apart and turning your toes outwards
about 45 degrees you're not going to be
turning at the ankles though or at the
knees you're going to be turning at the
hip work on this not only will you be
able to do those awesome black widow
landings not only will you be able to
kick super high but you'll also actually
improve your regular squat as you can
get your legs a little bit wider and
therefore get deeper into the squat at
the same time this is going to work on
your ankle mobility and strengthen you
in places that you're probably not used
to even if you normally have a massive
squat this is probably something that
you're going to really feel because it's
just not something that you're used to
at the same time we need to focus on our
torso and keeping our back nice and
extended and upright and our neck
elongated you want to imagine that
there's a piece of string coming from
the top of your head that you're a
puppet and someone is pulling that
straight upwards this is going to
improve your posture and your poise and
it's actually going to make you feel
lighter on your feet it's not just about
looking more aesthetic it'll actually
improve your jump height and your
general ability to move quickly and
lightly this is a fantastic form of
squat that you don't see people in the
gym doing and the only reason i can
think for this is because it comes from
ballet and i think that's an awful shame
in a demo plie the aim is to keep your
heels on the ground and just to squat
down as far as you can without letting
those heels raise off the floor in a
ground plie in a full plie you squat
down as far as you can allowing the
heels to come up off the floor but when
you get to the bottom of the movement
you should be going as deep as you
possibly can you're still not going to
rest on the heels you're still going to
be maintaining strength through the feet
in a releve plie you go up into the
balls of your feet and then go all the
way down like that this is fantastic for
actually training the feet themselves
which are brilliant for jumping and even
for jumping with a fully extended leg
you'll train your feet and your calves
which again are massively underutilized
by a lot of people in the gym and this
will help you run faster jump higher
generally perform much better again this
isn't just for looking pretty once again
you want to keep that pelvis tucked
throughout the movement so you have a
nice neutral spine this should help you
to stand tall and maintain your balance
a lot of this mobility comes from
concentrating on the right things and
from relaxing your body and the same
goes for your balance and your general
posture
in fact in order to balance you need to
be relaxed balance is not about strength
it's not about brute forcing yourself
into position in fact being tense is
going to get in your way instead you
need to focus on poise
on aligning your joints on letting
yourself listen to the reflexes of your
body which naturally want to get into
that position of alignment if you listen
to your body if you gain that mobility
and that control you'll naturally be in
a balanced position and it's from that
balanced poised position that you can
exert the most power and performance
another interesting example comes from
the cue to visualize a spring or rocket
while jumping using this simple
visualization technique studies show
that dancers can actually increase their
vertical jump i believe this works like
a form of chunking for the working
memory imagine throwing a punch and
trying to remember everything you've
been taught and a lot of people will
find that their attention and awareness
breaks down in the moment i know mine
does
by using visual cues however you can
help your body to automatically arrange
itself just as a mnemonic can help you
to remember a list of words all this
speaks to the real power of a dancer the
ability to coordinate every part of the
body around one central goal a great
dance looks beautiful because the dancer
is able to control every part of their
body with intent and power
we could be so much stronger and improve
our movement so much simply by being
better aware of our muscles and better
able to control them
got anterior pelvic tilt the solution is
not necessarily just to stretch the hip
flexors but simply to relearn how to
control the pelvis my planche training
has made a lot of progress since i
started simply focusing more on keeping
my arms locked during the pseudo planche
lean that same kind of awareness and
poise can help you in every kind of
movement lately i've been trying to
focus more on performing my exercises so
not just going through the motions but
actually trying to attack the motions
with as much speed and frost as i can
whilst at the same time thinking about
every part of my body is my core braced
am i squeezing my glutes is anything
flapping around or not where it should
be where am i looking focusing on these
things and thinking about it in this way
can improve your proprioception to the
point that you're aware of every part of
your body and where it is in space at
any given time so next time you're
training think a little bit more like a
dancer and you might find that your
movements become that much more deadly
and while she may be a fictional
character it also perfectly explains how
black widow can take down a much larger
opponent by moving fluidly powerfully
and with incredible precision just like
the ocean can break a sheer cliff face
it's nuts to me that we don't see this
kind of training in the gym more
[Music]
and we can combine this with other forms
of spy-like training to build a tactical
functional physique like the tactical
pull-up i talked about recently rope
wall climbs for entering buildings low
crawls for moving close to the ground
parkour rolls and jumps for traversal
carries for moving gear and supplies
endurance training to avoid fatigue long
distance running and sprinting at the
other end of the spectrum and of course
large amounts of combat training and
martial arts
that's how you build a black widow
physique
so thanks a ton for watching guys i hope
you found this video useful and
interesting definitely something a
little bit different today let me know
in the comments how you think black
widow would trade whether you think
there are benefits that you can get from
dance and from ballet in particular and
how they might transfer over to whatever
your chosen activity is the batman
training for 2022 is still on the way
i'm just working on something pretty big
and special for that at the same time
also putting together that montage of
bioneer training so go to the facebook
page and get involved if you want to
submit your videos before that goes live
and there's lots more exciting stuff on
the way if you like the concept of
combining different training styles to
get the very most functionality out of
your workouts and you might enjoy my
ebook and training program super
functional training there's a link to
that in description down below and i
also have a print book out called
functional training and beyond which you
can find at amazon and i'll put a link
to that as well
either way thank you so much for
watching this one guys and i'll see you
next time
bye for now